- Well, when I was about 16, 17 years old,
my cousin had met this
girl out of another city.
And you know, the girl came around,
we didn't know who she was.
You know what I mean?
We did a little investigation
on her to check her out,
but we couldn't figure out who she was.
Well, what we found out in the long run
that she was the type of
girl that came married dudes,
got into hoods and set guys up.
Well what happened was,
I was the one she wanted to set up.
I guess wherever she came from
they were speaking my
name in volumes out there,
'cause I was putting in a lot of work.
I was shooting a lot of
people, you know what I mean?
Sticking a lot of people,
beating up a lot of people
and they wanted my ass.
So I guess they got at this girl
and they wanted her to set me up.
So this is the way this scenario went.
I'm in the hood one day kicking it
and one of my homies tells me, hey man.
I get to the hood,
And every time we get to the hood,
we tell a homie, hey
there's a .38 in the bush,
there's a nine millimeter in the mailbox.
We let 'em know wherever the gun was at.
So I get there.
He tells me, hey, there's
a .38 inside the bushes.
Okay, when he tells me this it's me,
my homie, a girl and another
dude and my old lady.
He tells me he there's a 38 in the bushes.
If you need it it's right there.
So we're kicking it, boom!
About 15 minutes passed,
some dudes pass by, boom!
And the way we do it is,
if somebody passes by and they looking,
we let 'em go.
If they make a u-turn
and they pass by again,
you getting shot at.
So what happened was,
here comes a car,
Comes by they're looking,
they're looking, boom!
Turns around, makes a U-turn, boom!
I run out to the street, grab the gun.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, shoot the car up.
Must have unloaded the whole,
it was a revolver so I
unloaded all the rounds on it.
Shot the car all up.
It had flat tires and everything, it left.
Well, about 15 minutes later,
here comes another car.
Here comes the car.
This car don't pass it, it stops.
So, I walk up to the car and I look.
Lo and behold! It's the
girl, she's inside the car.
Now previous to this,
she had told on my cousin.
And he had went away for seven years.
She testified against him.
So my thing was, okay, I need
to get rid of this bitch.
For the simple fact
that she knows too much.
She's been around the hood so long,
that she knows everybody by name.
She knows where half of us sleep,
where we lay our heads at night.
So my thing is, we need
to get rid of this bitch.
So, what happened was, she drove up,
I walked up, I seen her in the car
and went back, grabbed the .38,
put it in my waistband,
went back to her car
and she has like an '82, '84 Cutlass.
It's either a Rig or a Cutlass,
I remember, it was light blue.
So I walk up to the door and
I tell her, hey, what's up?
Well, I'm not knowing at the same time
she's coming to pick me up,
'cause she's gonna take me to Pico Rivera,
to our main enemies.
She's gonna set me up over there.
There's like 15, 20 dudes
waiting for me over there.
I don't know this.
I find this out after.
What happens is, I get in the car.
She opens the door, picks up
the seat, I get in the back.
When I get in the backseat,
someone else jumps in with me.
Now this guy that jumps
in with me, is my homeboy.
But, I know that he's not capable of doing
what's gonna take place right now.
And what's gonna take place right now,
he is not capable of it.
In other words, he can't hold his water.
He don't got enough balls to
do what's gonna take place.
So as we're in the backseat, I tell him,
get the fuck out, get out.
And he's like, no, I wanna go with you.
I wanna go with you.
I said, no, get out.
He's like, no, I want to go with you.
Now in my head, I'm saying,
this dude can't go with
me, because he can't handle
what's gonna take place right now.
Well, he don't wanna leave the backseat.
We're arguing in the backseat.
Finally, I tell him, look.
'Cause there's two people,
she's driving, there's
another person with her,
I don't know this person,
but this person gotta go as well.
I'm gang banging.
I'm in the thick of things right now.
I'm getting there,
they're hunting me down.
Fools are looking at me from other hoods.
I'm shooting every weekend,
at the end was shooting
every weekend at me.
So, I'm thinking this dude
don't have the balls to go with me.
So, one thing leads to another.
I can't make too much of a commotion
in the backseat because she can see me.
She listening to us.
So I showed him the gun,
tell him, get the fuck out.
No, no, no.
I said, all right, you wanna go?
Let's go.
I tell her, come on, let's go.
So she starts driving.
By that time I take the gun out.
They say in quote transcripts,
I already got convicted.
They say I get the gun
and I put it to the base of her skull.
So everybody here, put a
gun to the base of skull.
Now, as we're driving,
I'm telling her turn left.
What the bitch does.
She turns right?
I tell her stop.
The bitch keeps going.
So, I have her, she don't want listen.
So I end up pistol whipping her one time.
Boom!
I don't break her head,
but I give her a pretty good knock,
'cause I hit her with the butt of the gun.
Boom!
Now she's paying
attention, she's listening.
But at this time, my homie
that's sitting next to me,
I turned to look at him,
he's really nervous, really pale
and I told him, I fucking told you,
get out the fucking car.
So now in my mind, I'm thinking
if I do her and I do her
I have to do him,
because he is not capable of
holding his fucking water.
So what happens is we're
going, we're driving.
What happens is, I say, well,
I gotta get 'em in a dark secluded area.
So what I do is, on the corner of
Telegraph and Pioneer Boulevard,
there's a bar that they call the Rim Ram.
Now behind the Rim Ram,
it's really, really dark.
There's a couple of dumpsters
back there, there's an alley.
So I'm like, okay, I'm gonna take care...
I'm gonna put 'em over here
and I'm gonna handle 'em.
What happens is, she pulls
over and back of that place,
it's really, really dark.
I get both of the people out of the car,
and this is in transcripts what they said,
that I put 'em both on their
knees, execution style.
What happens is, what my
homie testifies in court,
what my homie testifies and puts on paper,
is that I got 'em both out the car,
I turned around and looked
at my homie and I said,
I'mma smoke this bitch first.
This is what's said in transcripts.
Now, once I said, I'mma smoke this first
and I turned her on and put
the gun back on the broad,
as soon as I'm gonna handle my business,
my homie jumps on my back.
Now remember, he went with me.
He's my homeboy,
but he got so scared of
what's taking place, right?
And he want no part of it.
Then he jumps on my back.
When he jumps on my back,
we start to struggle.
The gun leaves my hand and
goes sliding across the floor.
Now at this moment, this woman's screaming
at the top of her lungs for the police.
By this time, I hear sirens coming.
I hear sirens coming,
so what I do is I get the gun,
I cut around the front,
and as I'm coming out the front,
I see a Highway Patrol Man
sitting at the gas station.
He has one of those explorers with him.
The ones that wear the yellow shirts
and go with them and they take 'em around.
They show 'em ropes and shit.
And my thing is,
by that time the cop is
excited, he hears the commotion.
The what you call 'em?
The little ride-along guy.
What he does is he runs
around the back of the car
and I see him hit the trunk real hard
to get the Highway Patrol's attention,
but at the same time, he's
gonna run across the street.
While Marty behind the car,
I got my gun out
and I'm like, you know what?
I'm gonna let this fool have it.
Y'all gonna catch me,
I just did this,
I know she's gonna tell on me, fuck it.
I might as well go out on a bang.
So what happens is I put my
gun over the car and I aim.
Now, this guy's coming
across a main street.
My thing is, once he crosses
halfway that main street,
and he takes one step off that curb.
I'mma send his ass back across the street.
Lo and behold,
I pulled it out,
I take my aim, here he comes.
I think what happened was,
he'd seen the shininess
of the gun, because when
he looked in my direction
if he would've took one
more step off that curb,
I would have sent his ass to kingdom come.
But what happened was he stopped.
He never took a step off the curb.
He turned around and ran
back the opposite way.
So that gave me time to escape.
So I'm running.
I hear sirens.
I hear the bird coming.
That's the helicopter,
I'm like shit.
So I'm running down an alley.
I see a set of headlights.
And I know the difference
between the cops headlights
and regular car's headlights.
So I see it's a cop.
Well, what I do is
I jump over one wall and I was thinking,
how can I stash this gun?
What's the best way I can stash this gun?
I'm thinking, I'm thinking I'm looking.
There's buckets and all kinds of shit.
I'm like, nah, they're
going to search right here.
Well, I look to the side
and I see there's a tree
in a backyard and it's a pretty big tree.
So what I do is I climb up the tree.
I break a branch and I
hang the gun by the barrel,
by the barrel and the trigger guard.
I hang it by the trigger guard.
So in other words, it's
by the trigger guard
just swinging on a branch,
pretty thick branch.
So I stuck it up there, boom!
I jumped back down, boom!
I take off running again.
I hear another cop coming
up the alley towards me.
What I do is I get under this motorcycle.
Now this motorcycle has a blue tarp on it.
But when I went to get
under the motorcycle,
I end up hitting my leg
on one of the pegs that
stick out the side,
where they put their
feet when they ride it.
I hit a peg and I split my damn leg open.
So, at this time I'm
already out of breath,
I'm holding my leg, I'm trying to wrap it
with the headband that I have,
but it's bleeding profusely.
It's bleeding a lot, because I
cut it on that big old spike.
Well, I don't know what to do
so, I go and get a water hose
and I'm wetting my leg
down, wetting my leg down.
All of a sudden I hear another
car coming up the alley.
I know they're cops because
they make a whistling
noise with their motor,
and when they put the brakes,
for some reason they're always squeaky.
Their brakes are always squeaky.
So now I'm like, man, what am I gonna do?
What am I gonna do?
How am I gonna get away from this?
So I wait, I wait, I wait,
here comes another car.
As soon as he passes me,
I shoot across the street.
Now I'm running down the street,
down the street from a distance
I see another, there's
so many cops around.
Just so many cops around.
Every second car is a cop.
Here comes another cop.
What I do is I dive and I
get into a little flower bed.
It's a little brick, flower bed.
And I remember I'm
laying in the flower bed.
I'm trying to catch my breath
and I see the lights just
going over me, back and forth,
back and forth, back and forth.
And I'm like, oh man.
I could just imagine what
these cops want to do to me
due to the fact that all
these cops know me by name.
I know the broad gave up my first name.
She was married to my cousin,
so she knew exactly where I lived.
She knew my name, what they call me.
And I knew that previously these cops were
passing word around that
they wanted to kill me.
This was coming out and I'll share
that they wanted to kill me.
This was good detectives,
for other that was being done
and they were blaming me.
And I'm not saying I did
it or I didn't do it all.
Yes, I took part in some of it.
But, I know they want to get me.
So I'm really worried
about when they catch me,
what do I do?
Do I raise my hands up?
Do I pick my shirt up?
What do I need to take my shirt off now
So you see I don't have a gun
because I know they're gonna looking
for someone who's armed and dangerous
because the simple fact
that the girl must've told
them that I had a gun.
So, I go to my homie's house.
I'm hiding behind his garage.
A car passes, another cop passes.
They're all shining their lights.
I mean, within a, maybe
a 10 to 15-second window,
I see my girlfriend
coming with her mother.
And they're going real
slow through the hood.
I get up to a bush, I wait.
As soon as they pass, I run
and I dive inside the backseat.
Boom!
Soon as I get in the backseat.
I tell him, go, go, go.
So we leave.
I end up getting away.
But, what happens is she
knows all my information.
So they start raiding
all my family's houses.
They're raiding all their houses.
They're walking around with
a flyer that has my picture
on it and says, known
gang member says my name
what they call me and then bottom print
says attention known to
be armed and dangerous.
So they went around showing these flyers
to all my homies, to my family.
My grandmother gets one.
She showed me the copy.
And I'm like, whoa, they
looking for me that bad.
Well, I'm not knowing that
they already stuck all
kinds of shit on me.
So, they want to get me for two murders,
four counts of kidnap.
And in juvenile
I have holding a concealed weapon.
And discharging a firearm
within an inhabited dwelling.
So I had this juvenile.
I got this in the door now.
So I'm on the run.
I'm on the run for maybe, Ooh shit!
I was on the run for maybe 18 months.
And I went to Arizona.
I went to San Luis Obispo.
I went to San Francisco, Oakland.
I went back to Arizona
and it was weird because
everywhere I was at
as soon as I felt uncomfortable,
I would leave, a day or two
later they would hit the house.
They went all the way
to Arizona to find me.
They went all the way to
San Luis Obispo to find me.
And they were right on my tail.
I mean, they were right
on my tail so close that,
like I said
every time I left one or two days later
they would hit the house and
I'd be like, Oh man, shit!
You know what I mean?
There are on me so intently
that I'm also finding
out information from the Sheriff's station
because we have a few girls
that actually worked there
as those Explorers and they worked inside.
So they give us vital information
about what's going on.
We went to school these girls,
we're older now they're getting jobs.
So, they work inside there.
So we're getting vital information.
Lo and behold, I find out
that the Newark sheriffs
have their own Newark
Sheriff's 10 most wanted.
I'm number three.
The reason number three is because
the two guys in front of me,
they've been wanted longer,
and they have packed more,
Could we say more bullshit on top of them?
They've charged them more.
They're getting more charges.
So (clears throat) I know I'm number three
on the Sheriff's ten most wanted,
I know they're passing a flier om me.
Armed and dangerous.
And with a .38.
Mine they put the caliber of the gun.
So, I'm thinking in my head,
man, when they catch me
they're gonna kill me.
When they catch me they gonna kill me.
Well, within these 18
months you can imagine.
I ran from 'em so many times.
I got so many times
close to getting caught.
I always got away.
I was running them up.
I had a gun, 24/7 in my waistband.
I didn't leave without a gun.
Now I'm walking around in this thing shot
with a gun in my waist.
I'm banging in some apartments
that I already sewed up
I have the manager even dealing dope.
So, I have the whole apartments.
Sewed up. I got any room I want.
There's empty rooms that people
leave all their furniture.
I just take over the room.
I'm supplying the manager with dope.
So, I'm like the real manager.
So we're living there,
you know what I mean?
And I'm knowing that eventually,
the Newark Sheriffs are
gonna find where I'm at.
They're gonna just hunt me
down eventually do their job.
And they're gonna find me.
Well, I'm on the run.
And I'm really getting tired of running.
I'm getting tired of
running for the simple fact
that I cannot lay anywhere
comfortable at night.
I can't trust anybody.
I mean, I gotta be careful where I'm at.
'Cause if there's a lot of people there
and someone calls the cops,
they're gonna come out
running and I'm gone.
They're gonna know who
I am once they get me.
They gonna identify me by my tattoos,
had my tear drops on
my face since I was 15,
I'm 17 now I'm gonna be 18.
So, they are real familiar with who I am.
But like I said, I'm
running around everywhere.
I'm having people drive
me here, drive me there.
I went inside the trunk.
I've let people sit on top
of me in the back seat.
So many different things
because I'm on the run.
And It's so intent me.
And, right now, as it
stands, I'm fighting,
I'm willing to fight some life sentences
because there's kidnaps, there's murders.
And they're just trying to
place all kinds of shit on me.
So what happens is one morning
I get up and it's like a ritual,
every morning I get up and I
check the traps that I have.
What I actually did was I was
living in the corner apartment
on the bottom of a complex.
And I was in the corner.
I had one window,
we'll say on the South
side of the building,
and another window on the
East side of the building.
What I did was,
I got big old pieces of glass.
I broke big old beer bottles of glass.
And I got the biggest shards and pieces.
And what I did was,
I put them inside the ground
next to my back window.
What I did was I set
'em in different spots.
And then every spot I did have a piece
of glass sticking out the ground.
So somebody would step on it.
And you know, I would hear him because
everywhere there wasn't a piece of glass,
I put an aluminum can.
So my mind was thinking
if they came to my back window to get me,
they see the aluminum cans.
They're getting to
avoid the aluminum cans,
and step in the area
where there's not a can,
okay they're gonna step on the glass.
When they step on the glass
or the nails that have put in the ground.
Once they step on that and
it penetrates their skin.
Now they're gonna step everywhere
and I'm gonna hear them step on the cans.
I'm gonna know somebody's
in the widow and I'm
gonna let them have it.
I'm not gonna ask who's there, no.
Once I hear those cans getting crushed.
I'm gonna let 'em have it.
Whoever's there, I'm gonna
fucking pump them full of lead.
This is my mentality because in fact,
I'm on the run for some serious crimes.
And you can imagine what I did
from when I was on the run.
I didn't care anymore.
You know what I mean?
I was going every weekend
to everybody's hood
and I would hit him four
or five times in one day.
Four or five times in one day.
Just hit him 'em four or
five times each of them,
because of the simple fact that
I was the only one out there
really really active in my hood.
So, that morning I wake
up, I do my little ritual.
I check my traps, both sides of my window.
Everything's cool.
You know what I mean?
I get Miguel with my cat, my room
I got a couple of cameras set up outside.
I check parking lot, check the driveway.
You know what I mean?
Everything's cool.
Well, luckily I grabbed my gun.
I take it to my homie's
apartment a few doors down.
And we smoke a li'l bit of dope.
We get high.
We're talking about what
we're gonna do today.
And I tell him, you know
what, I'll be back, man.
I'm gonna go to my house so quick.
I'll be right back.
He's like, all right, go ahead man.
So, I get my gun.
I stash it under his bed.
I go to the house, my girlfriend's there.
I have a newborn baby, maybe
about three months old.
She has the baby right there
and we're kicking back,
we're talking all of a sudden
I hear boom, boom, boom.
At the same time, I hear cans.
Start to get crunched.
So my first thing is,
but I ain't got my gun.
I left my gun at my homie's house.
I come out the front door because
when I looked out the peep hole
there must've been 15
fucking cops lined up
ready to come in the door.
I have through my peep hole
I see just all kinds of
faces and all kinds of guns.
And I'm like, Oh my
God, what am I gonna do?
I go to the back window, look out.
I ain't going no where.
They got dudes post up on both
sides with fucking shotguns.
Ready for me to come out the back window.
So I'm thinking, damn, what
the fuck am I gonna do?
What am I gonna do?
I couldn't do shit.
I'm gonna fake that I'm asleep.
So fuck it, I laid down.
Boom!
They kick in the door.
They charging, grab everybody,
put everybody on the floor.
Now mind you, I'm giving 'em a fake name.
I have no ID.
I don't carry ID.
So I'm giving 'em a fake name.
I think I gave him something
like Joe Chavez or something.
They run the name, the
name come back clean.
I can't believe that
I'm about to get away.
The name came back clean.
I just gave him any name.
Any birthday.
It came back clean.
But about 10 minutes later.
I see a fucking car pull up,
and I see a detective get off the car.
This detective knows me by face.
Soon as he comes up and sees me,
We got him! We got him all!
They all look at me.
Oh man, they must have beat my ass
for about five minutes.
They were kicking me
hitting me with the fucking
flashlights they had.
One had his fucking foot on my neck.
The other one was taking shots at my ribs.
He bruised my ribs for like three months.
They split my lips, busted my eye,
messed up all my neck.
He stepped on my neck so hard.
That he actually pushed my
Adam's Apple so far back that
my throat was hurting
for about three months.
Well, they end up figuring out who I am.
I give my real name
they take me to the station.
Now they're telling me
all my charges that I'm
getting charged with.
Most of them was bullshit.
Couple of them. Yeah.
They got through evidence,
they got through chatting.
They got through people who are telling,
they got through snitches,
through reliable performance.
So, I'm debating how
much time I'm gonna take.
So at that time I hit the County jail.
And at this time the County
jail is still active as hell.
Still got big homies on the line.
Still got fags running everywhere.
And I don't mean that bad by that,
but you got homo sexuals
running everywhere.
The County is just a straight jungle.
It's just out of hand.
So I get there and every time I'm there
and I'm having a ball, I'm having fun.
I'm making pruno, am buying dope.
Everywhere I go, I got a cheer.
I get the keys to Rikers.
So, I'm in charge of everything.
So everything that comes in
and out has to pass my hands.
Every type, every money
order that people buy
dope with comes passes my hands.
I log it in, put my log away and send it
wherever its got to go.
Well, I'm in there fighting my case.
I'm thinking right now they're trying
to give me 35 to life.
That's where they're at. 35 to life.
They don't wanna go down,
they don't wanna move.
I'm trying to tell him 'em
I'll take 20 years right now, 20 years.
I even went to 25.
I told 'em I'll take 25 years right now.
Nope. Nope.
We ain't giving you nothing.
So we wait, we postpone trial.
We postpone trial.
What happens maybe about two weeks before,
No two days before we pick jury.
The Highway Patrol man that
was at the scene of the
crime and everything.
Ends up getting into an
accident on the freeway
on the 605 catching the 90.
Some lady ran and hit him
or something on his bike.
And he was no longer with us.
So went to court, they tell
us right there in court.
The officer that did the
arrest passed away previously.
So all they can use is whatever
he said in the beginning.
Can't use anything after
'cause he's no longer here.
Just what he wrote in the police report.
And the police report was all fucked up.
Now, I wanted to find a
discrepancy in my case on
where can I beat my kidnaps?
Because my murders they
already dropped them.
They got me on two counts of kidnap.
And I'm thinking damn!
where's the discrepancy in my case?
something where I can fight this.
Lo and behold, I'm going
through my transcript.
And they're saying
that I'm being arrested and tried
for two counts of kidnap.
But if you remember,
in the beginning of the story,
I explained something,
and I said,
when I supposedly put the
gun to the base of her skull,
I told her turn left.
She turned right.
I told her, keep going.
She stopped.
I told her stop.
She kept going.
So when you really look at it,
I was never ever in power of her.
I never really took command
and made her do things
she didn't wanna do.
Everything I told her, she
did the exact opposite.
Now mind you, we're
supposed to be a 12 inch gun
to the base of her skull.
She wasn't obeying my commands.
So, at that point, I said, wait a minute.
How are they trying to
convict me of a kidnap
when I never ever had actual
control of this person.
That drops it to attempted kidnap.
Maybe even false imprisonment.
Because I never was in command.
I never actually,
at one time if I would
have told her to turn right
and she would have turned right,
well then I was in command.
I had control.
But due to the fact that she did not
obey my commands.
I was never ever really in charge.
So I went in court.
And I told my lawyer
which I had a paid lawyer.
He charged me $12,000.
That's what he charged me to represent me.
That was just to go in there.
And I get at him, and he's pretty good.
He's, out of Newark,
but he wasn't too bright up here because
I seen what he didn't see.
Then when I brought it to his attention
he kind of got upset
'cause he didn't see it.
But I told him well
I got the idea from you
when you were telling
me the other day about
you explained to me what about the case
and I drew it off of
what you were telling me.
And I came up with, Hey,
I was never a control.
So, how are they gonna me for kidnaps?
I never kidnapped anybody,
because the fact that I
totally never had control.
So we go in court, we present that.
And all of a sudden, they're
talking about 15 years.
And I'm thinking wait.
15 years.
I just got them down from
35 to life to 15 years.
Fuck it. I'll take it.
I said, I'll take it.
I was 17 years old.
I figured I'll get out when I'm 30.
By that time, you know what I mean?
Likely to be older.
You know what I mean?
I won't be so radical with my beliefs.
I believe I will be so
devious, so cunning.
So mean at times, so awful, very terrible.
I was very, very sick individual.
And, I figured I went to prison
I'll get a little bit of schooling.
You know what I mean?
I'll get some education.
I'll find some new ways
to commit some crimes.
'Cause that's what jail is.
If you want to know how to do something,
you just go to jail and ask.
Somebody will tell you exactly
step by step how to do this.
So, I end up taking the 15.
We get to court.
They give me six years for one kidnap.
Six years for another kidnap.
And then they wanna give me
another three for the gun.
What gun?
There is no gun.
They never found the gun.
If you remember,
in the beginning I said
I climbed up a tree.
I broke a branch and I hid
the gun by the trigger guard.
You know that gun sat there
for all the time I went to prison.
I went to prison six years.
I sat for six years in prison.
When I got out, I went
back and got my gun.
I went back and got my gun.
Now, the reason I got my gun is because
when I got out this time,
I was living the family life.
You know what I mean?
I had a job, I had a
nice car, nice apartment,
and very beautiful wife,
beautiful daughter.
And the hood kept calling.
They kept pulling me.
Well, all my brothers, all
my cousins there for my...
and there's one of my cousins that
he's like a brother to me.
So, I get a phone call at the house.
My wife answers.
Here. They want you.
Boom! I pick it up.
It's my little brother.
He's like, hey, we need to meet.
We need to meet.
I'm like, wait a minute.
You need some heat?
What do you mean?
I've be gone away for six years.
You guys been out here.
You guys don't have no heat?
You guys want my shit?
Nah, you ain't getting my shit.
So they're calling, they're
calling finally my aunt calls.
What the hell is going on here?
These guys are digging
up the whole backyard.
You need to tell them where it's at.
I'm like, I ain't telling
'em where shit's at.
Yeah.
Finally . She's gone so much.
I get at my little brother.
I tell him, look man.
I'mma tell you exactly where it's at.
Do you know that I told him
exactly where it was at.
They dug up the whole fucking backyard,
but never touched that one spot.
I told them where the gun was at.
I think I should've told
'em it was everywhere else.
And they would have dug on that one spot,
'cause they had to call
me to go over there.
So I go over there and get
to my grandma's backyard.
They're all back there.
Sweaty, all dirty.
And I look at the yard
and there must've been at least
15 to 20 holes, big holes.
And I'm like, my grandpa
has his yard very nice.
There's holes everywhere.
I'm like, Oh my God,
these fucking dudes, man
I fucking gave 'em
thorough, thorough, thorough
Map how to find it.
You know, I told him, come
here, stupid motherfucker.
I dig him up.
I pull him out.
I must have like seven guns in there.
They been sitting in there, you know?
So I pulled out three of 'em.
I get one to my uncle,
one to my elder brother
and one to my cousin.
And I tell 'em look, those are for here.
You walk around here and use those.
You don't go to another hood and use them.
No, that's not what these are for.
These are strictly for our hood.
So when people come
in, we let them have it
and get them back out.
Well, I gave one to my
brother, one to my uncle.
You know, my uncle lives
in the middle of my hood.
My uncle, I go to his house one day and
ask him, Hey, where's
the gun that I gave you?
Oh, I got it.
Okay. Well I need it. Lets se it.
Do you know this guy when he
got a fucking power drill.
And he fucking started undrilling screws
from the wall in the garage.
And I was like, what are you doing?
He said, I'm getting the gun.
Really? You're kidding me.
You got the gun locked
behind a wall, bolted in.
How are you supposed to get to this,
when you have to handle
business when they come
they're not just put timeout
and let you take all these screws out,
get this out and then let 'em have it.
No. So I ended up taking it back from him.
And am thinking, damn!
I cannot drive from my hood
to my house with a gun on me.
I'm a third striker.
What am I gonna do?
So I'm looking at my truck.
I'm looking at my truck.
Boom! I see my big fee...
I got a 1500 base up,
Two big old, 15 megabase speakers.
And they're in a box.
So what I do is I take the box apart.
I get the gun and I tape the
gun to the inside of the box.
I put the speakers back on.
Put the speaker back and I drive home.
I never even took it out of the box.
I left it in the box.
I drive there where I got
pulled over several times.
They searched everything,
never found that gun.
That gun came in handy when I needed it.
It was very nice.
But, what happens is I end up getting...
went back to time,
I end up getting ...
They end up giving me 12 years.
They get mad, 12 years.
And when I get the time, the
homies they're talking about
you're gonna do every last day of it.
You're gonna do all 12 years.
So am kinda of upset,
you know what I mean?
Its my first one, I can say
that I didn't put in much work,
but, one time I'm sitting up there
and East max in the County jail.
And I see these two individuals,
are getting escorted.
And a few more images are coming.
And then three more come.
And they started catching me.
I grabbed the card, get it,
take your business, put it away.
Because you gotta whoop a hot ass pack.
'Cause you cannot walk around
with ice cane County Jail.
You get caught in County
jail with the hot ass cut.
You get your ass smashed.
And you owe $200 fine.
No, you get caught with one of those,
you owe $300 by, three days.
If you can't handle those $300,
it doubles to $600.
Then it goes to $1200.
But I don't understand
when they keep doing that
because, if the fool
can't pay the first 200,
What makes you think he can pay 600?
What makes you think he can pay 1200?
You're charging him more money
when he can't even pay
the initial few hundred.
And that's the way they do it.
So, I get the cut and I hoop it.
I take it back to where I'm
at, where I'm housed at,
I open it up and,
unless its orders from headquarters,
how to handle some business.
You know what I mean?
And where I'm going, wherever I end up
they're letting me know,
Hey, no, one's there.
Get it grab it, sew it up, get back at us.
And that's a yard.
So, this my first term.
I really don't want to get
involved with a lot of shit,
but I mean, just because
of where I'm from.
And because of who am related to
a lot of the bullshit just follows me.
It just surrounds me.
I mean, there's dudes that know
who my uncle is or who my cousin is
and they come and ask me for advice.
They want me to give them
the permission to do this.
And I'm like, no.
I'm not gonna give you
information to do shit.
'Cause when it comes down to it,
you're gonna put my fucking name in there.
And, I'm not gonna answer for bullshit.
You know, I can speak volumes
about certain things here
and I will speak about it,
but it always keep names
and shit out to protect the innocent.
Am not out here to tell on anybody,
I'm not here to give
out vital information.
I'm just here expressing things
that I have been through.
Things that I've been through life.
Places that I have been,
where I've gone,
and what hits me up in
my head and tells me,
the worst place I've ever been.
And I've been to 15 different prisons.
I've been to the harm
I've been everywhere,
but the worst place I've ever been
was the LA County gang module.
And I've been in a lot places,
I've been in a lot of situations,
but when I hit the LA County
Module for the first time,
I remember exactly what happened.
We got caught for a ride,
they took us all downstairs.
They fucking filled out paperwork
And then they lined us up
and they took us to the
tier We're gonna be on.
Now as we're walking, I'm in the front.
Because I was the first one
they wanted to interview
because of my hood and
we were all active with
and they wanted to put me in the GMR,
So, I was the first one they talked to.
So, I'm in the front of the line.
As we cut through what
they call the module.
We cut through the module,
we're going to able roll.
It's all the role its last
and the end And on the bottom.
Do you know that when we made that left
and then we made that little right
to get in front of the the door
then when I made that left
and I made that right.
When I stepped up to that door,
I felt, I don't know if it
was a good shift of air,
or something, but I felt
something hit my chest so hard
that I hit the two dudes behind me.
And the dude behind me,
the dude behind the guy I was behind said,
what the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
I didn't know what it was.
I Still today don't know what it was.
All I can do is
give it
just a name and try to explain
the best I can on what it was.
Me, I think it was straight death.
That's what I think,
because, when I got on that tier,
and do what I had to do
and everybody else did
what they had to do,
I knew right after that,
that that's what that really was.
And like I said, I've
been to a lot of places.
I've been through a lot of prisons.
You know what I mean?
Bloody alley, all these fucking spots.
But never, ever have have I felt
such tension, such anger such
hate hostility in one place.
When that thing hit me in my chest,
it didn't feel cold.
It didn't feel hot.
It just felt plain nasty.
A feeling inside my
body where I understand,
after I figured out I knew
it was death that I felt,
but I'm honest with you,
it hit me so hard that it
knocked me into two individuals.
I never realized it behind me.
I never felt nothing like that.
But I knew once I got on that tier,
once I got on that tier,
five minutes later I
was stabbing somebody.
Five minutes later,
I was stabbing somebody.
And I only had been on
that tier for five minutes.
I didn't even get a chance
to put my shit down.
Because of the fact that,
when you get there,
they put you all in one cell.
And you're all packed in
there with about seven dudes.
And they all got big ass knives on 'em.
Now what they're doing is,
they get your name,
your booking number,
and they send it to the streets.
On the streets, they called County.
get all the information,
give it back to the
person that we call again.
And all information comes back.
But mind you, during this time
that information is going back and forth.
You can't put your shit down.
You can't sit on nobody's bed.
You got to stand there
and wait all that time
for that to come back.
Due to the simple fact that
if one comes back wrong,
he's getting handled on the spot.
You know what I'm saying?
And, you're sitting there
and you're waiting and
dudes, they're like vultures.
They're like piranhas, circling the tank.
They're hoping that somebody's shit's
gonna come back dirty.
I know where my shit is
because of the simple fact
that when they're about to run
my shit, they're already
handed me the phone.
So, I get on the phone.
I talked to...
So, I put my shit down.
You know what I mean?
I was already to the point
where I already known people.
I putting work.
I did my thing.
So, they don't have to run
my name in black and white.
I'll just tell 'em to whoever you're
on the phone with, tell
them, you know what I mean?
I'm pretty sure they know who I am.
And that's what happened.
Yeah. They told somebody that
I was there and they said,
Hey they wanna talk to you.
Man. Here we go.
Here we go.
You got there, got NEA.
You do this, do that, do this.
And I was like, all right, cool.
So,
about 20 minutes later
they tell me that somebody
has to get handled.
Something that, I mean,
somebody has to get stabbed.
So, they tell me, can you do this?
And have it go on locked in,
pass this.
And but yeah
First down there, I'm
already on the chair.
They cleared my name.
The other dude, they
are still in that room
waiting for the name to get cleared.
Sometimes it takes hours.
That's why we took a whole day.
The dudes didn't even sleep.
Who they're waiting on
information to come back.
'Cause you're not allowed
to put your shit down
and relax because we don't know
Who you are.
What you're busted for.
We're waiting for it to
come back from the streets.
Like I said, if it comes back all bad,
you're through with the money.
They're gonna kill you on that chair.
They're gonna do what
they have to do with you.
And they're gonna take
as much time as they need
because of the simple fact that
that's all we have is time in there.
Time is so good,
but your time is so evil.
Because, there was a guy,
where I was at in that game module.
And dude used to come
for situations that happen out
there with them on the line.
'Cause we're slammed down, okay.
But dude would get there.
And I picked this up along the way.
I watched how this guy did it.
What he did was the dude would get there.
And he has to yell on the chair
what he wants to talk to 'em about.
He's like, hey, we'll call this dude Jojo.
He's like, Hey Jojo, can you tell me,
on paper?
What happened out there with you?
So Jojo gets the paper, they
send him a pen and paper.
He writes it all down.
Dude gets it, reads it, lets me read it.
And then folds it up and puts it away.
Jojo's like, hey wassup ,
I got that, its touchdown.
Don't worry about it.
And the guy,
Jojo waits a whole week and
never says nothing about it.
The next week.
Exactly. A week later,
he's like, Hey Jojo.
Like yeah, A up.
Remember what you wrote
down the other day?
And they hit the pad
I had to get rid of it, bro.
Can you write it down again?
Yeah. So you wrote it down again.
So, we waited and mind
you we're in the back.
We're not going anywhere.
Everybody's stuck right there.
So, he's been a patient.
About a month later,
he said he had it quiet on the chair.
I need to talk to somebody.
So everybody gets quiet and chill.
You can't make no noise.
You make a noise, you get
your fucking ass smashed.
But you can listen to what's
going on all you want.
So, he calls Jojo.
Hey Jojo, yeah what's up?
Aye go ahead and tell
me in your own words,
what happened out there?
And he tells me Johnny,
we're in the same cell
and he wants me to get where he's at.
What he does is he puts the
two papers down side by side.
The one Jojo wrote in the
beginning and the middle.
Now we're gonna hear Jojo's story.
And he tells me, wait
up Jojo, this is Johnny.
Get this paper, that
paper, listen to his story.
If anything in his story,
is not what's right here
on paper, he's lying.
And I already feel he's lying.
So here we go.
Jojo just starts talking about his story,
and his story is not adding
up with what he wrote down.
So, what the dude did was
he used time as friend.
What he did was he had Jojo
write it down one time,
write it down again.
And now he has him telling it.
So, he's gonna tell a lie.
The story is gonna change
because it's a lie.
He's making it up as he goes along.
It's not actual fact,
Actual fact is gonna be,
this paper and this paper
and hi story, are gonna be identical.
Because it actually took place.
Now this is what I picked up.
And I used it along the way
when I was in situations.
And I wanted to know what
happened to this dude on the yard.
Does he gotta, Could he stay?
I'd use that scenario,
and it was something
that I learned in jail.
And it was so good that,
what made the guy think
of something like that.
I mean, you, you got a lot
of time in jail and you think
about a lot of shit,
but who would actually think of, okay
I got this dude back
here with me for months.
I'mma tell him to tell
me his story three times.
And if it changes it's Zass
and Jojo was not there no
longer with us like a day later.
Jojo got, they went the fuck out a Jojo,
because of the simple fact that his story,
didn't add up.
Tt was totally different than
what he had written down on paper.
So, I share with you because of the fact
that I learned so many things in prison
that I brought out here with me,
and I utilized in a good way.
I don't use him in a bad way,
the way he used it with Jojo.
You know what I mean?
Because that was when he was so patient.
And you know, we discussed
about me being patient.
I learned to be patient,
from these guys in here
that were patient men.
You know, because they're very patient.
Being patient, that's a virtue.
It's a good thing.
And it is,
but there's certain things
that you can't be patient with you.
There's certain times when if
you be patient with this guy
he's gonna take more advantage of you.
He's gonna not wanna
pay you what he owes you
or, he's not gonna want to give you
whatever dope you have coming.
I admire prison in a way,
where prison made me
very very humble.
It humbled me in a fashion where
not saying that it wasn't
handling business, no
I always handled business.
That's not going to stop.
What I mean by humble is,
I learned things in there
in certain scenarios where,
In other words, I wouldn't
even think of that idea.
I wouldn't even Phantom the thought
of making a man, tell
her story a couple times.
They catch him in a lie.
It's so devious in there.
And they play so many
minds games in there that,
I see guys just lying.
Lying in line.
They got another thing
in there, sad go in there
and I take something that belongs to me.
It's for me.
Well, I have to give a third of that.
Give it away.
To someone I don't even know.
I don't mind it because it's right.
But I don't like where
he had to go in upstairs.
By the time it gets upstairs
it'd been touched like 15 times.
So what I sent up there, it's
not actually getting up there.
I might have said five grams
and they only get a half.
But it touches so many
hands as it goes along.
Because it has to reach its destination.
But at the same time,
you're dealing with dope fiends,
thieves, connivers,
everything you could think of.
Bonds, you know?
And so many people are touching that that
you gotta remember where you're at.
You're at where they motherfuckers
commit all kinds of crimes.
And if you're gonna send
somebody to the ground,
you know is liable to get touched.
There's dudes that will take that gamble
and touch something.
But literally they know,
these things are wrapped
in a certain way where
it's red with the green balloon.
It came from the streets
with the green balloon.
And if I green balloon
inside jail and rewrap it.
So if they get that issue
and they open that issue
and that green balloon breaks,
it's their ass.
'Cause you can't retire.
It's tight. So tight
with a little ass knot
if you wanna eat get in it,
you have to actually break that.
And if that green balloon is broken,
somebody touched that issue.
So, that was something else I learned.
They do so many things in jail where
they do it to a point where
they know if something's been touched
or somebody's been tampering with shit.
I seen a Bible.
A Bible that every third
page had nothing but $50.
These were heroin.
Inside the Bible.
Now there's a Bible just got handed,
from the priest to the homie.
He had an, a Bible with that much dope .
And every third page.
He would iron it so thin,
that they would actually
put 10 of them in there
and iron shut superglue
the pages together.
So when they got the book and they went.
'Cause they're just gonna
run their finger along it
see if anything would fall out.
Nothing's gonna fall out
because everything is
sold in the pages.
But the best one I ever seen was
a dude got a package,
with some basic Cheetos.
He tells me Johnny, come on.
we open the bag of Cheetos.
He pours them all on top of a
piece of plastic in his bed.
And he goes,
boom! Do you know that they put
little yellow straws,
about that big.
Back then with dope.
Got the Cheetos.
Another bag of Cheetos.
Putting them in a pool,
crunched them all up,
put a little bit of water.
Then they got the straw,
pack it with dope from both ends.
And then got the Cheeto and just,
put the Cheeto together.
Remember a cheeto doesn't
have any shape to it.
There are different sizes in it.
They got the cheeto
and they put all this
stuff back on each straw.
So there was 30 straws inside each bag.
There was four bags.
Each bag contained 30 straws inside.
But you couldn't see the straws
since you got the cheeto and you actually
either bit it or took it apart.
But, that was the best thing.
When the dude put the cheetos down.
and he grabbed them
he went (breaks cheetos)
and then he went up and
he showed me the straw.
I was like, what the...
Heroin, glass, weed.
But the way they did was
they made the little straw
and then they just put
the Cheeto back together
threw it back in the
bag, sealed the bag back.
Shook the bag and send it on its way.
'Cause anything on the ground,
doesn't get x-rayed.
Only in the air.
If you say you're sending something
you don't want to get tampered with you,
you send It out on the ground.
Just two months ago, we
received the box in the mail.
Not addressed to us,
but it was just in the mailbox.
So we got it.
I sat it on the refrigerator.
Didn't touch it for a whole week.
Finally I was like,
what the fuck is in this box?
Do you know I opened that box
You know what was it was in there?
Two ounces of glass
and an ounce of heroin.
And found it in the mail, found the mail
just found the box on top of a mailbox.
So it was just sitting there.
I'm like, I'm taking this box.
Fuck it.
Been sitting there for three days.
Mind you, was sitting for
three days outside, outside.
I grabbed it to go and put it up on there.
I didn't think twice of it.
But when I opened it,
that's what was in there.
An ounce of heroin, and
two ounces of glass.
Don't know who it's going to
'cause I know it had a fake name.
But it just happened to come
to our mailbox is at, so I grabbed it.
So, as I was hitting
that was like, you know,
being in jail, you pick up so many traits.
A lighter that just has a flip,
that just flicks,
Know the flame to it,
is just as good as a lighter that works.
How you do is get some toilet paper,
get it twisted up.
Leave a little bit of it sticking out.
There's some lick from your sock,
put it on top of that toilet paper.
You have the lighter,
turn it upside down,
scrape it, till a little
flip falls on that link.
And then you just flick it. It ignites.
That's just the way it's get fired.
And the other one is,
there's a light socket.
Get two pieces of lead.
You need three pieces of lead.
He had two pieces of lead,
and you stick 'em inside
the socket, each socket.
Then you get another piece of lead.
Hit toilet paper,
fold it over,
twist the ledge with
the lead sticking out,
you got the toilet paper and you tap it.
And it explodes with another
piece of toilet paper
you have on the side,
it explodes, it explodes.
And then it lights this whole paper.
And you have a light.
Now ,Before I would not
stick any that of outlet,
but because we're in a place where
we actually need the light,
I have to stick the lens
inside the fucking outlet.
Nine times out of 10
I'm the one out there working another tier
'cause I want to know
what's going on in my house.
So I'm the one working on a tier.
I've popped that.
Like I popped that sucker
so many times where
I took the power on and half
of the building one time.
And that shit must've blew
up and leads got shot.
Like bullets.
They hit the walls.
It just blew up too big.
I went to hit it.
It blew up and fire came out
and it just blew those leads.
and it shot the leads everywhere,
blah, blah, blah, blah blah.
You want to be.
You learn so many things in jail
how to do things, how to make shit.
And then so many dudes are
telling you how to cook dope.
You know how to sound dope,
what not to do the next time you get out,
they run you down so much shit that,
I think in there you get out
more of a devious person.
You get out with more vital information.
It makes you,
it made me
A very cautious individual.
I'm very cautious with what I do.
I've did so many things in
jail and got away with them
I've been to places where dudes are like,
how the fuck ain't you
back here yet with us.
I just plan my shit out.
I go plan A plan B and plan C you know.
If you're gonna stab a dude on a yard,
you have to have some getaway plan.
You know what I mean?
Cause you're on a yard.
And as long as you have to
an extra set of clothes.
you have to think of it ,
so good to get away with it.
My only thing was to get away with it,
To get away with it.
I did things and got away with it.
Because I just didn't jump the gun on.
I'm not that individual that wants to go,
around all kinds of points
and stab a dude right under the gun tower.
No.
I'd rather be the guy
jogging around the track
and the third lap run by
I just stick it in his neck
and just keep running.
And then running the handball court
and take those clothes off.
Plus the piano and start playing handball.
But the time they hit the
buzzer and get this dude,
I'm already done sweating
playing handball games.
People see me playing handball.
And I've did it within the nick of time.
Within the Nick of time.
I've hit a motherfucker and
stepped out of my clothes,
right into Some other clothes.
And got away with it.
I got away with so much shit,
but I was saying, you know, it's
because jail makes you a
whole different type of man.
A whole different type of individual.
You see it all there.
You hear every lie.
You see every story happened over
and over and over and over again.
And people think,
Oh man, as Johnny he
knows what time it is.
No, Johnny has just seen the same scenario
that you're in right now happen
with just different individuals.
With the same thing happened.
Now, the way I'm gonna do it is okay.
Now I want to handle the situation.
Okay. I can do it this way,
but damn, last time we did it that way
it ended up all back.
Or I can do it this way.
The way I seen it
in all these times and
everything just came out good.
So, they'll come with problems.
I'll give them the answer.
Then they'll go back and
say, how did you know?
Because I seen the same scenario happen,
over and over and over again,
but just different individuals,
just different men.
The only thing different
is every man acts.
Reaction is different.
You got dudes that you can pump up
and they'll go handle business.
But as soon as they're
done handling business
they deflect and become
that weakened can visual
that they were in the beginning.
You just pumped him up and
gave him a little bit of,
you know, yeah, I can do it.
And when after they do it,
they are no good to you anymore.
They're what you call,
Expandable.
You become expandable.
You become, yeah, it's expandable.
Yeah. You become expandable.
You know,
We don't need
We don't need you wejust get rid of you.
'Cause there's like 50 more motherfuckers
that'll be in line.
Yeah. Because you know
us being Southsiders
we never run short in jail.
If they move 50 of us of the yard,
50 more back on.
So, you know, it doesn't really matter.
I want to share that with you today
about things I learned in jail,
and I share them with you,
due to the fact that
these are things I learned
and they take me through life.
Now I use them out here
but I use them mainly
in a positive manner.
Some I still gotta use
negative because there
are some dudes out here that
need a throw ass whooping.
You know what I mean, Mark?
I got you on mic,
anytime brother, you know.